[Music]
hello everybody did you know that Jake
Kane news is also in podcast form for
all you people out there that are
[ __ ] at the same time to listen to
podcast hey make sure that if you guys
want to check us out on the podcast you
can check on those links in the
description box below and remember to
give us a good rating because we need
that love some of us out here not
feeling loved food news food by
submitted by 60 shady Steve yeah that's
shady I don't know what shady Steve I
just know a fantastic one and innocent
bystandard to a restaurant scuffle wins
$100,000 after being you here in the
face with pasta Wow assault with a
deadly linguine I would love to get in
the face of a pasta yeah alright because
I want to eat it okay I don't get it
not lasagna sounded really weird cuz
it'll be so hot here on the murder I
feel like the [ __ ] about to make a
second one no oh my god you're crumbling
it no I just did exactly so the next
one's name is Tycho pie attack oh no was
the original name that we never Tiger
tolerate Oh Reese can we please
inventory yeah you can you guys win yeah
it was a cute name okay you got it it
would be like what why Laurita yeah
alright so this story is about this
woman she was eating at an Italian
restaurant in Connecticut as she was
leaving there was this lawyer named
James Sweeney who got news good who got
into an argument with another man and as
this woman was leaving the lawyer picked
up his full dish of pasta that had spicy
sauce in it
lunge it at the plate ooh
just was it like seth's that's serious
question never know what the restaurant
plates are they true don't I think since
he's a lawyer he's probably it knows it
so if I just grab the plane just only
probably felt like the temperature of
the pasta to do this okay it's not that
hard I'm gonna Brendan yeah he probably
plus it up in the air so it's not
malicious either yeah I don't know
exactly how the toss went down iron off
the plate was still involved but the
whole point is that it did fit it did
hit this woman straight on her face and
it was spicy sauce so she's saying that
the sauce got into her eyes causing her
to hit her head get a concussion I get
it
I pain and neck pain and back pain we've
had a friend of ours put a bunch of
sriracha in our eyes yeah it's not nice
okay we all know that pain yep how do
you get back shut the [ __ ] up cuz I got
the worst of it and I did it to myself
but you they have a swing the whole
Serato not forgotten the roof I forgot
how much it hurt okay anyway I forgot it
was in the sheet at the moment it's not
it's not what first-degree murder that's
like [ __ ] accidental murder which one
is that the fifth degree murder no I
figured it didn't involve some burning
though maybe like first-degree
manslaughter oh that [ __ ] was a act of
passion if that was a gun I've been
shooting myself to what the [ __ ] were
they arguing about about this yeah I
don't know they were arguing like like
what the [ __ ] man I ordered [ __ ]
white wine not lawyers left to argue
they do boys arguing all day and [ __ ]
yeah but and Laurie throwing a full dish
of pasta
hey we saw a lawyer [ __ ] tell a bunch
of people to go back to Mexico and then
we caught him again saying some other
[ __ ] - oh [ __ ]
oh yeah there's like so there was like
some yoga handsome model guy with his
girlfriend and he was just vlogging and
then that [ __ ] lawyer guy was like
you [ __ ] immigrants go back this guy
looks like a tall white guy
like you [ __ ] immigration lawyer yeah
the same one cuz he saw that video and
he's like holy [ __ ] I this guy harassed
me and my girlfriend yeah and then he
posted that vlog so he has multiple [ __ ]
like he goes around New York just being
racial to white people too that was just
not you to his so he use doesn't know
what he's doing he's even know how to
racially profile people yeah that's
crazy yeah he went up to a white guy
like what the [ __ ] bun like the yoga
white guy
yeah and he was telling him he was
telling him go back to your country you
immigrant [ __ ] get out of my way and
[ __ ]
it was [ __ ] like what his
girlfriend's blonde is Howard [ __ ]
no they're just vlogging they're just
vlogging like walking in and he just
comes up to him he's like you're in my
[ __ ] way get off don't even touch me
or whatever and then he just puts the
camera on him people out there that just
need to be slapped oh yeah yeah slap
some sense into me there's a lot of
people like that not so much like the
racist thing but like how they just say
whatever the [ __ ] they want and nothing
happens to them all the [ __ ] time
dude I'm telling you man because I think
sending a mariachis I mean that's cool
you know it's like the legal thing to do
but I really want to see him get [ __ ]
Dawg you know what they should have done
they should have just put an opinion in
front of his face and just go full at it
yeah so back to this lady here so the
jury awarded her eighty five thousand
forty nine dollars plus interest for a
total of a hundred and two thousand five
hundred and fifty dollars yeah I would
never throw food that I just paid for
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
in my life I never think of using food
as a weapon that's like a that's like a
thing of love you know not even when
you're angry
no dude there's like [ __ ] free bread
that they give an Italian places that
are way harder and there's Forks
there's cups knives knives there's those
little [ __ ] glass vases with the with
the rose there's tables and chairs
there's candles you forgot about the
chairs
oh yeah the candles yeah take the napkin
roll it up light the candle [ __ ]
throw it on mother
in a wine bottle there's so many weapons
[ __ ] go to the lobster tank you put
it on their [ __ ] face those buy back
waistband I never think yeah I don't
think about throwing my food that I just
paid for I know that's crazy like even
if like I knew like the food could
really hurt them like a boiling hot bowl
of oats coke tried the food and it was
disgusting
I still eat that paper yeah me too I
think the point is to humiliate them so
like just think about them humiliate oh
yeah not just a [ __ ] movie no when I
thought I thought the red wine yeah yes
I'd rather give them on a black eye than
like Oh got you yeah yeah it's super
[ __ ] I think most people though they're
worried about it like lawsuits and stuff
especially there's convict suits you
would they are to do it they gotta do
that hood thing you know me where they
go outside and they just do this point I
[ __ ] love ghetto people I've seen
this happen so many times it's just one
phrase oh by the way people if you
haven't run around ghetto people if they
say this one word to you do not go to
him let me talk to you for a second oh
yeah that's all they got to do let me
talk to you for a second and then [ __ ]
their ass up that's tight they don't
want to talk we're gonna beat you up
dude outside take it outside
what do you want to verbally tell me huh
don't lean in yeah if you're not ready
to fight yep mmm I sense animosity got a
message for me yeah my man friends I'm
gonna keep my cards out of my fist fight
with my pockets you approached Colorado
in a really weird way yeah but this made
headlines cuz it's just it's so funny
cuz she was just innocently walking by
and she got awarded over a hundred
thousand dollars man what would I do
with $100,000 getting hit in the face
with pasta the three hundred thousand
you should get hey what the plate though
she asked that earlier I don't know
that was it I was just thinking of all
the different weapons I could be using
at a restaurant besides food David said
that before the weapon happened yeah as
you did I just picture like spaghetti
getting car ahead - meatball Italian
food
yesterday doobie Oh MEAP I did oh oh no
we do everything together but oh I found
a place in America that's the closest
pizza that I've tasted to Italy
it's called North Italia and the chain
there's one in a Manhattan Beach there's
no one Newport Beach keep on the pizza
like the because what really makes
Italian pizza I think different from
here is the pizza dough that's really
really soft like you don't you can eat
like a billion crusts in your jaw never
gets tired and this dough was like
spongy and soft oh my day you know those
Italian pizzas no men sometimes I look
at them and I get a little mad because
they're like this is your margherita
pizza I'll say well thank you for giving
me ketchup and bread so where the [ __ ]
is the rest of my [ __ ] you know like a
big gas card I would like cheese to
cover the whole [ __ ] thing oh that's
not Italian they put like $1 and there's
just all tomato and this little basil
leaf I'm like [ __ ] you you bastard what
do you mean doesn't look loaded yeah
Italy when my dad was traveling in Italy
he said that he had a really long day
and so by his hand me sat in a
restaurant he saw pizza he's like oh man
I can't wait to have this pizza so you
ordered one and the whole time he was
just thinking of an american-style pizza
and when the waitress brought out the
pizza to him it was just like this thin
crust thing of like bread and then there
was just like some sauce and like little
toppings on there and then my dad would
like what the [ __ ] is the pizza I think
this is not pita
but you know what's Delta that's where
it started yeah
but you know it's dealt out because it's
so light you can order like two or three
different ones are they cheaper it's one
that's like this big and that's like
purpose that's smaller than a pan people
you know what I like the best no beyond
that kind of [ __ ]
New York Pizza slices are my fave I like
New York Pizza - lets just take that
[ __ ] fold it in half like this like a
taco yeah you know I judge people I
don't fold a pizza I'm not a pizza I
don't fold it you're naughty Peter which
way do you fold it you fold of
horizontally or it has to be like a roll
it has to be fun huh like this yeah like
what the point is yeah I've seen some
people like literally fold it in half
and I seen other people like like
symmetrically if they fold it that way
you have to slap them no are you telling
us right now that's what your boyfriend
does then leave [ __ ] leave him now no
those real big pizzas though I have to
fold those what the regular burger you
don't fold a hamburger do you know I've
seen people full doing you got a half
I've seen it though yeah yeah it's like
one of the most upsetting things I've
ever heard in my life
yeah and they bring the tip to the know
what you just told me right now is like
you literally just told me you got a
hamburger and you flip the buns inside
out and used to beg you ate it that's
what you just told me right now hey I
don't judge you got a slap they eat it
however they want to eat it I prefer not
to hold at all yeah the sandwich meat on
the outside the inside what's going on
here when you get a double-double do you
prefer the meat on the outside yeah you
don't hang out with those people anymore
do you thing out with us do you
understand we're good people you like
your drink outside of the cup floor ever
since she left the iPhone gang and then
went
it's been a different Julia we just were
not connecting it by the way update I'm
getting a pixel to that stone that an
iPhone now still coming in today
[Music]